je leur donne des missions il essaie de
relever la première j'ai donné à valérie
et qui aujourd'hui c'est quoi les ça je
vais trouver un chroniqueur est arrivé à
lui faire dire 5 saloperies sur vous non
donc il sait pas du tout qu'il est filmé
et ont bien avant il a compris c'est que
série c'est un vote je trouve que je
l'aï ska super album ça dort son quad
est trop chou nos villages avec des
mains regarde quand il est quand il
avait fait son régime en décembre tout
ça est que la alors là vous avez réussi
à garder du muscle voilà il m'est arrivé
de grave à la venue des pavés qui
mangent des chips himmich a tout le
temps un saut dames tout j'en conclus
boissons sucrées un truc est due au
succès tranquille en baggy du conte
barrages ils perdent sc qu'avec la fin
de la journée et le look de bord je
trouve agréable en ce moment on il a
toujours été casse-couilles quand même
un élément aimable peut-être retrouve
quatrième des fresques en toi les
arrivées après il vrai de temps en temps
écouter quelques bonnes paroles dont la
tienne est la mienne on n'est pas si
nombreuses
heureusement quand même c'est quoi ta
baisser un petit peu dans son annonce
[Applaudissements]